it isn't all doom and gloom there are
some glimmers of hope when it comes to
climate change
[Music]
and realization across society that we
need to rapidly reduce our carbon
footprint
net zero by 2050 blah blah blah net zero
blah blah blah climate neutral blah blah
blah words that sound great
but so far
has led to no action
second the uk has cleaned up its
electricity faster than any other major
economy back in 2010 more than three
quarters of it was generated from fossil
fuels only a small proportion was from
renewables now more of electricity comes
from wind solar and hydro than coal and
gas
how did that happen well great leaps in
renewable technology and efficient
production lines have cut costs by 2025
solar farms are expected to produce
electricity at half the cost of a gas
power station
[Music]
third electric cars are also
accelerating
the best-selling car in the uk in
september 2021 was the tesla model 3 and
it was pure electric sales of electric
cars are up 88 on this time last year
and in europe sales are expected to pass
1 million and a year for the first time
ever
energy and transport are big sources of
carbon so going green is helping the
global effort to cut greenhouse gas
emissions
[Music]
it doesn't get much more important than
the environment at the end of the day
does it with the pandemic makes a step
back a bit and just look at the world a
bit it's going to be inconvenient it's
going to be very expensive
but people are protesting that we're
burning the planet at the paris climate
summit in 2015 countries agreed to limit
warming to below 2 degrees and aim for
1.5 by the end of the century
before that some climate projections
suggested the world was on course to
warm by 4 or maybe even 5 degrees even
with all the efforts to cut carbon the
world is still a way off the paris
target
at the moment we're heading for a
temperature rise of 2.7 celsius by the
end of the century assuming countries
make good on their promises
so progress in reducing emissions
doesn't mean we can relax time is
running out if we're to avoid the worst
effects of climate change
you